So who's my guest this week?
The British lawmaker and activist,
Baroness Jane Campbell.
When you've originally been
given a life expectancy
of two years, you know how to
make the most of your time.
Born with spinal muscular
atrophy in an era
when the world was an
even harsher environment
for those with disabilities,
she's fought politicians around the globe,
challenging segregated schools,
battling for access to
transport, independent living,
and then became a politician herself.
She was made a Baroness
in the UK Parliament,
blocking laws for euthanasia,
even in the face of some
passionate advocates
who are pleading to die.
If I should ever seek death,
the last thing I want is
for you to give up on me.
She says disability isn't
her problem, it's society's,
and she will change society.
Here's a taste.
What is top of your list to achieve
for those living with
disabilities around the world?
I just want them to feel alive
and I want to enable them, in some way,
to feel empowered, because
once you feel empowered
and you have a bit of
confidence, you can do anything.
Hello, thank you so much for talking to me
and to all of us today.
Hello Emma. I'm very pleased to be here.
I wanted to start by asking
about spinal muscular atrophy
and what it means to you
as someone living with it?
To be absolutely honest, I
don't really think about it.
I don't wake up in the morning and think,
"Oh, I've got spinal muscular atrophy.
What's gonna happen with my body today?"
I just tend to get on with life.
I've lived with it since I was born,
it's part of who I am.
My impairment doesn't define me,
but it certainly is a reason
for why I am sitting with you here today,
talking about some of the things I do.
Because my impairment, my condition,
whatever you want to call it,
is something that I'm just used to.
It's my friend, it can be my enemy,
it gives me a hard time sometimes,
and it is progressive.
So I have to keep up with it
and keep inventing new ways to do things.
And when people, if they
say to you, "What is wrong?"
If they even put it like that
to you, do they say that?
All the time.
Right, so what do you say?
I recognize that your
relationship with it's different
and you've only known this.
Absolutely.
Well, it depends on what kind
of mood I'm in, to be honest.
If somebody comes up and they're young
and they're, you know, knowledgeable
and I think they should know better
and they say, "So what's
wrong with you, then?"
I normally go, "Well, I'm
a bit broke at the minute,
but apart from that, I'm fine.
What's wrong with you?"
And then they'll go, "Well,
no, no, no. I don't mean that."
And I go, "Oh, what do you mean?"
And if they want to pursue it,
but by this time I hope
they get the message,
they will ask me, "No,
what's your condition?"
You know, "Why are you in a wheelchair?"
And I go, "Um, well, that
depends. Why do you want to know?
What would you like me to tell you?"
Because I want people to think
what is behind that question.
Why do they want to know?
I was going to ask about
assumptions people make,
and perhaps some of the
more frustrating ones
that you just wish weren't
part of how you were perceived.
I think they assume that I must be in pain
or that I must be upset
that I'm in a wheelchair
or that my life doesn't
have the same things in it
than theirs does.
They think that, for some
reason, I don't go to the pub
or I don't go to see a
performance of "Swan Lake"
at the Royal Opera House.
Because how would I? I'm in a wheelchair.
That still happens.
It's a lot, lot better, but, you know,
in my youth, I couldn't go into a cinema
because people thought I was a fire risk.
You know, somehow I wouldn't get out
and I could get out the cinema
probably quicker than you.
It was your dad, I
understand, who never took no
for an answer for you.
No, my dad was more
bloody minded than I am,
and he was always determined
that I would be treated
exactly the same as my sister,
which was tough on me at times.
You know, I had to do all
the same things as she did,
you know, chores around the house.
Okay, I couldn't take them tea in bed,
but I could do the wiping up.
I was treated equally at home.
I wasn't treated equally
anywhere else, but I was at home.
So he would drag me and
my sister to museums
and parks and the circus
and he'd even hoick me
up on the merry-go-rounds
and in the bumper cars at the fun fair,
because he wanted me to experience
what it was like to be just ordinary.
And he pushed me hard.
Well, we are hearing some
of the fruits of that
in terms of where you've got
to and what you've been able
to do, which we'll also
come into more detail.
But just something you said
about getting to people's homes
and if they asked you what they could do,
it made me think of I read a recent report
of someone preparing to
take a refugee from Ukraine
and they are repurposing
their home for a family
who have a disabled son,
he's in a wheelchair,
living with disabilities.
And I wonder what your reflections
are thinking about that,
because when we think about
war, we don't necessarily think
about those who are
living with disabilities.
Yeah, I think the first
moments that we were hearing
about what was happening in Ukraine,
I immediately thought about
the 2.7 million disabled people
that were living in Ukraine.
I was thinking, "Well, what would I do
if suddenly I couldn't be in my home,
and I was down in a tube station
and there was nowhere to
plug my ventilator into?
I would be dead."
So this war is going
to profoundly affect the
lives of disabled people
and those who are at the most
vulnerable edge of society.
And we already know that
there's a lot of children
living in some of their residential homes,
because they do still have
a lot of residential homes
where kids are shut away.
Some of them, I have heard,
have been just left there to die.
Because, you know, in many ways
it's the survival of the fittest
and I'm afraid that is true.
We don't like to think about it.
We all think about compassion
when it comes to, to disabled
people, to older people,
but there is a dark side of all that
to where there isn't the compassion,
to where actually vulnerable
people of any sort
are subject to bullying and left
to fend for themselves.
Yeah, I haven't heard
anybody talk about that.
No, you won't.
We don't even talk about
it in our own country.
No, but with regards to
war, in this most recent
situation.
Yeah, well that's what
I'm trying to find out at
the moment through the UN.
You have the UN Committee on
the Rights of Disabled Persons,
and they have set up some charities
directly for this purpose of finding out
where are they, are they still
alive, and how can we help?
It's a very important area
of work to keep going with,
even in war.
Absolutely.
But I think absolutely the
idea of survival of the fittest
is something I'll definitely remember
when we're thinking about this,
'cause I hadn't thought
about it in those terms,
even though I was thinking
about just this family,
trying to prepare their home
for a wheelchair.
Good on that family.
I would want to go and give them a hug,
because not many people
would think like that.
And the survival element has been key,
especially when, as you say,
you are up against a
deteriorating situation
in your own body that you're
trying to keep ahead of
and you made the decision
to be fed by a tube.
It's a big change in your life.
It was, yes.
How has that been?
And I suppose there must be things,
like you miss out on the
social side, in some ways,
of dinner at first, or you
may be concerned about that.
Tell me about that.
I mean, there's a lot of cultural norms
around sharing food.
You get invited to dinner,
you have work dinners,
you have social dinners,
food, food, food, and suddenly,
food wasn't gonna become an option for me.
And I liked food and I
loved going out to dinner
and I loved socializing.
You probably found out I'm
a bit of a chatter box,
so I enjoy all that.
But it wasn't going to do me any good.
In fact, it was gonna kill me in the end.
So it was something I had to get used to.
I went through a period
of loss, of course I did.
But I can tell you, what, nine years on,
I don't even think about eating food.
Now, strangely enough, I
still like cooking food.
So I like cooking for my friends,
I like going to dinner, to where food is,
but what I did have to do,
because all the invitations
immediately dropped off,
so suddenly I thought, "Well
this is half my social life
has suddenly come to an end."
And I wasn't gonna have that,
so some of my friends, I said,
"Oh, I didn't get invited to your dinner."
And they said, "Well, you know,
we can't bear to sit there
and eat in front of you,
'cause we feel for you."
And I go, "Well, actually I
feel worse when you exclude me.
So I'll come to dinner,
and put a nice glass
of Chardonnay on the
table, and I'll be fine.
In fact, make it Champagne,
I'll be even better."
So I'll sit,
and I'll drink, 'cause I can easily drink.
Coffee, I've bought myself
a good coffee machine
and I'm love with coffee
and all kinds of drinks.
And ice cream, I can still eat ice cream.
And I'll be fine.
And again, it was, I had to reassure them.
You said about, if somebody asked you,
if I asked you about your condition,
what would it actually tell you about you.
So much of your life, you don't
wish to be defined by this.
And yet your work has made
you extremely well known
in this area about rights
for others, equality.
How do you marry that up,
not wanting to be defined,
but so much of your work is around access
for those living with disabilities?
Well, I suppose because I am not defined
to being just a disabled person,
talking about my own experience.
I'm interested in equality for all.
Typically, I don't just work on issues
to do with disability,
I support my colleagues
who are doing work around race equality,
and I do like working with
a lot of women's groups,
because I actually think
that intersectionality
is incredibly important,
because I could be a Black woman
or I could be a Black disabled woman.
So, there are different
parts of you that, basically,
they speak to different characteristics.
So one day I can be sitting
around the board table
with some of my colleagues
and they can ignore me,
not because I'm a disabled
person, but because I'm a woman
and I'm sitting with some very, very male,
stereotypically male,
characters, and I have to really
be forceful in order
to get my point across.
I think I prefer to say that I work
in the field of human rights.
And I just want human rights-
Well I think that speaks-
For everybody.
I was gonna say, that speaks very closely
to one of the campaigns that
you are very well known for
around the world.
But if you look at the UK,
which is where you have a role
in in the legislation, for
blocking assisted dying
becoming law in the UK.
Yeah, it's a tough one.
Others have worked with you, of course,
but most recently you did this last year
and it does keep coming back.
It's not something that
goes away for a while
and countries around the world
have moved to legalize it.
Why are you against it?
I think if we lived in a
world that treated people,
sick people and disabled people like me,
equally with respect and not with fear,
then I would feel quite comfortable
about having assisted suicide legislation.
But the truth is that, and
we just know this by looking
at our recent pandemic.
Within the pandemic, disabled people
disproportionately suffered
as a result of the pandemic.
It was extraordinary, nearly
6 out of every 10 people
who died with COVID in England
were disabled or underlying
health conditions were given
as the pretext for that.
But, I mean, it was extraordinary.
It wasn't because we were
more subject to getting COVID.
In fact, when colds are going around,
I probably am the last one to get one,
'cause I'm very robust.
It's because we didn't
have the same access
to intensive care or ventilators.
Even one of my friends, who
is also a ventilator user,
was told she couldn't have
filters for her ventilator
because they had to be kept for people
who were fit and well and getting COVID.
And it's true that, when I went,
I found I had bowel
cancer three years ago,
and it was quite serious
and I needed an operation
there and then, my
consultant had to basically
advocate for me to have that operation,
because the view is that
actually I'm at end of life,
that this is what I'm defined as,
because I have a progressive impairment
and that I was less likely-
So what, perhaps,
you wouldn't want to be
operated on for bowel cancer?
"Well, why would we operate
on her, because she's
likely to die on the table."
Why? I don't know why.
"And also her recovery, you know,
what would her life be
back like after recovery?"
And it's a lot of clinical assumptions.
Again, my mother was told, you know,
"Your child won't live till she's two.
Go home and enjoy her."
Well, this month I
celebrate my 63rd birthday.
So I know that there are
so many assumptions made.
So is that your fear that, you know,
there's a kind of euthanasia
policy there that isn't being
advertised?
Oh, I know there is.
There's plenty of examples.
I could tell you of a time, 15 years ago,
when I had pneumonia and
I had to go to a hospital
that doesn't know me, and they said,
"Well, we're not going to resuscitate her,
because in her condition,
it wouldn't be fair."
Was this said to a family member?
It was said to my husband,
and my husband had to go home,
and I'd just received a
doctorate, an honorary doctorate
for some work that I had done,
and he brought the picture back
of me in my graduation gown.
He said, "This is my
wife. She works full time.
You do for her everything
else that you would do
for anyone else who
has that kind of life."
You know, "She's in her 50s.
Why aren't you giving her antibiotics?
Why wouldn't you resuscitate her?"
And it was only at that
point they began to see me
in a different light, and
it was all that load of,
"Oh, she's got SMA, she's on a ventilator,
she must be end of life."
So to be clear, though,
those are incredibly worrying examples,
and those are only from your life.
You will have heard many, many others.
But for those who, and you
will have spoken to them,
who are in a situation where
they really do want to die,
they're in an enormous amount of pain,
it isn't a life for them
anymore, as far as they see it-
Absolutely.
and they need assistance.
How do you speak to them about your view
and the role you've played
blocking what they want to become law?
What I say is, at the moment,
there are not the safeguards.
There is not the kinds
of attitudes that we know
that would safeguard
thousands upon thousands
of disabled and older
people in this country
who need palliative care
and who need the support
to live with dignity and not in pain.
And until that's there,
if we brought in this bill
for these one or two exceptional cases,
we will be putting hundreds
of people in dire risk.
I mean, this-
We should say
you were a protestor, you
know, long before you were in-
I was.
And you may still feel
you are, but I meant that was
very much what you were doing
for a long time.
Yeah, but I was doing
women's rights before I was
doing disability rights.
Well, I didn't just say
in this area, though.
You were a protester. That was
a lot of what you were doing.
What was the naughtiest
thing you got up to
as a protestor that you
wouldn't be able to do now
as a member of the House of Lords?
I took 50 wheelchair users.
We made sure that most of us
were in electric wheelchairs,
'cause you cannot lift them,
and we just crossed Westminster
Bridge and we stopped.
And we stayed there
for an hour and a half,
and we got little placards out
saying, "Rights Not Charity,"
because we wanted civil rights.
We didn't want to be
seen as charity cases,
that we had no civil rights,
no right to go in any building,
no right to stay in your own home,
they could put you in a
residential home at any point.
No rights, absolutely none.
Not to go on a bus, not to do anything.
And so that's when it all began.
And I just thought it was
the best day of my life.
And what did the police do?
They didn't know whether to arrest us
or give us an ice cream
and pat us on the head.
To be absolutely honest,
they were bewildered,
because here are all
these, what they thought
were poor pathetic creatures,
sitting in the middle of the road,
going, "Wotcha Officer?"
And they would say,
"Would you please move?"
And we went, "Sorry, battery's dead."
And we were just winding them up,
and they kind of quite liked it.
The second time we did it,
they were a bit more prepared.
So they walked us down
to the police station,
but of course it was
two steps up to the door
so we couldn't get in.
And so they tried to get us in.
You know, it was difficult.
There were some deaf people with us,
they demanded a sign language interpreter,
someone else wanted something in braille,
and in the end, they just said,
"For God's sake, just go."
And this was our time, and it
was a very liberating moment.
And that's why we often talk
about the disability movement
and they say, "Well, what was it?"
And I said it was our liberation struggle,
just like women had many years ago,
and we had to go through that period
of being suffragettes and throwing bricks
or sitting in the road.
But then it was time to negotiate,
and I think that's when
I became very interested
in politics and the political machine.
'Cause I knew, at the end of
the day, we needed legislation.
I wanted to ask, what is
top of your list to achieve
for of those living with
disabilities around the world,
if you could get one thing
really in a better place?
I want them to feel personally
in control of their lives.
I want them to believe that
they have life chances,
that they can get a job, or
if they feel they can't work,
that they can contribute in some way,
whether that's artistically,
whether that's socially.
I just want disabled
people not to sit at home,
watching daytime TV, and
feeling sorry for themselves,
because that makes them socially dead.
I just want them to feel alive.
And I want to enable them, in some way,
to feel empowered, because
once you feel empowered
and you have a bit of
confidence, you can do anything.
Honestly, you can.
Well, yeah,
Even block the road
with a group of your friends.
Yeah, stop the traffic.
I did promise that I
wouldn't do it anymore
when I went into parliament.
Baroness Jane Campbell,
thank you so much for talking
to me and to all of us.
Well thank you, Emma.
It's been a real pleasure. Thank you.
And thank you so much for being with us.
Until we meet again,
take care and goodbye.